well now another covert 19 vaccine is
under scrutiny after a few cases of
blood clotting
u.s health authorities have recommended
a pause in the use of the single shot
johnson johnson jab
as it investigates those incidents the
food and drug administration has
stressed that this is a precautionary
move
but also in the past few minutes the
company has announced it will delay its
rollout in europe
well we'll be speaking to stephanie
decker in berlin to get more on that in
just a moment but first let's speak to
our white house correspondent
kimberly halcott in washington d.c now
kimberly the government there's already
been struggling to deal with vaccine
hesitancy i don't imagine this whole
johnson johnson situation is going to
help much with that
well the white house has just released a
statement saying that they believe
that the pause in the johnson and
johnson vaccine being administered in
the united states that has been
recommended by the cdc as well as the
food and drug administration
won't have a significant impact on the
overall
vaccination campaign to put into context
the white house saying that
the johnson and johnson vaccine made up
just five percent
of the vaccines being administered the
majority of vaccines being administered
in the united states are made by the
drug companies pfizer
as well as moderna now the white house
saying just moments ago
that the pfizer and moderna doses that
they have secured enough to
administer 300 million americans
shots so they do believe that they will
remain on track for the
uh revamped goal of 200 million shots
administered
by 100 days in the byte administration's
first days in office so
there is still a sound of optimism
despite this
what is being viewed as a setback for
the global vaccination
effort and also the effort in the united
states the concern being that
well it is a small number that the
effects
of the johnson johnson vaccine that
could cause potentially very serious
blood clotting disorder in other words
what they call a
thrombotic event or cvst now what we
know
is this has happened primarily to women
between the ages of 18 and 48
but less than a dozen cases still out of
an abundance of caution this is being
reviewed
by the centers for disease control on
wednesday and the recommendations made
by that body will be presented to the
food and drug administration
but again out of abundance of caution
this is being paused but the white house
saying
this will not have a dramatic effect on
the vaccination effort
in the united states kimberly halcott
there our white house correspondent with
all the latest thanks so much kimberly
well let's now go over to europe and
speak to stephanie decker in berlin
steph over there first astrazeneca and
now johnson johnson another setback
for the continents vaccine rollout
absolutely i mean across europe the
vaccination rollout has been
sluggish in some areas a little faster
than others but certainly when it comes
here in germany
there have been it was a slow start
certainly
um they were expecting the johnson
johnson vaccine to arrive here
mid to late april europe has actually
bought around 2 million doses
of the johnson johnson vaccine to be
distributed
among its member states so there hasn't
been any official reaction so far but
certainly just from reading between the
lines of course this is going to
dent what has already been a sort of
slow vaccination campaign what's better
about the johnson and johnson vaccine so
to speak in terms of time is you only
need one doses
whereas the pfizer vaccine the biotech
pfizer and the modern one need two doses
administered
from a couple of weeks from each other
it's also easier to store it can be
stored in a normal refrigerator for up
to three months
so these are the things that make it
more of a let's say attractive vaccine
when you're trying to get your
population vaccinated in a fast amount
of time and certainly we were talking to
um
the head of the the medical
practitioners here earlier today and he
was saying
one of the key issues was the fact that
they were lacking
vaccines and they needed to get more
vaccines into the country to be able to
vaccinate people at a quicker pace
to keep up with what is now a third wave
uh
here in germany so certainly this news
that fine out of abundance of caution
johnson johnson is stopping its
deliveries but it's only going to slow
um the vaccination campaign even more
and steph you mentioned that third wave
happening now in germany
the country is also now trying to
centralize its pandemic response there
how is that all going over
yes this is basically because uh the
german chancellor angela merkel has uh
been frustrated she's been trying to
impose stricter lockdown she's been
talking to the 16 heads
of the regions in germany and what's
happened over the last couple of weeks
is that they've been implemented
to varying different effects across the
country regardless let's say
of some areas of increasing numbers and
we've had warnings from different
medical
heads and voices and even politicians
over the last couple of weeks
that if stricter lockdowns do not get
implemented um
that the third wave of this pandemic
will increase that hospitals
will get over capacitated that icu beds
will get filled
so this is the concern so what they've
done now is they have passed through the
cabinet
legislation which would give the central
government absolute power to impose
these lockdowns
on the different states it still needs
to pass through parliament but if that
passes and we're looking at that
potentially later in the week but it
needs two thirds
then the central government can impose
things like nighttime curfews from 9 pm
to 5 a.m it can close schools if the
numbers go up to a certain extent it can
impose that
only families from one family can only
see one person from another family a day
i think it's very
difficult to impose but these are sort
of the measures that they're looking at
stephanie decker there across all that
for us from berlin thank you so much
steph